johnny knoxville is one of america's
most recognizable daredevils but which
stunt forced him to use a catheter for
three years you might not want to know
the answer and more things you might not
know about the jackass forever star just
ahead johnny knoxville born philip john
clapp is no stranger to injuries in
hospital visits but he also
unfortunately had many medical issues as
a child in an interview with rolling
stone he details the asthma issues he
had as a kid and which he still deals
with today he told the magazine it was a
really nice childhood and i was really
cuddled but i was also sick a lot his
asthma was so bad that he couldn't do a
lot of classic childhood activities like
playing in a pile of leaves knoxville
even had stints in which he had to spend
several days to a week in the hospital
he said he almost died at the age of
eight as a result of having the flu
pneumonia and bronchitis all at the same
time yet his chronic lung disease didn't
stop him from playing sports because he
quote didn't want to be left out or feel
like a victim johnny knoxville is
technically a classically trained actor
even though his training was never
formally completed according to the new
york times knoxville moved to los
angeles after high school and attended
the pasadena school of dramatic arts but
he dropped out after six weeks knoxville
told the washington times that he had
wanted to be an actor since he was 13
because it sounded like a job with the
least amount of work involved as luck
would have it knoxville would eventually
make it in the acting world without a
fancy degree yet it took some time and a
unique career path before he made his
way to stardom before jackass was born
knoxville was a writer for skateboarding
magazine big brother where he pitched
the story about testing self-defense
equipment like pepper spray and stun
guns on himself magazine editor jeff
tremaine suggested knoxville film the
experiments and the rest as they say is
history
knoxville's inaugural acting credit was
an appearance on the ben stiller show in
1992 it wasn't a major role as knoxville
was a featured extra as a cure fan other
roles audiences might have missed
knoxville and include a college guy and
coyote ugly in 2002 as well as bob and
desert blues in 1995. though he had
already made a name for himself by the
time he took the part audiences might be
surprised to learn that he voiced johnny
krill on spongebob squarepants but while
knoxville has played a plethora of roles
outside of the jackass franchise most
people would agree that his greatest
performances happen when he's just being
himself knoxville is widely known as a
stunt performer and actor but fans might
not know that he also has numerous
writing credits knoxville has 15 writing
credits on imdb including projects such
as jackass presents bad grandpa action
points and many others including the
mainline jackass movies he told gq in a
2021 interview writing gave me
confidence as a person it was like i
don't have to just worry about trying to
make it i can do this and feel satisfied
and engaged luckily for fans in
knoxville alike the writer turned actor
did make it and he even turned down some
big opportunities along the way
many actors had become mega famous after
appearing on nbc's iconic sketch comedy
show saturday night live but johnny
knoxville turned down the long-running
show right around when he was shooting
the jackass pilot in a 2005 interview
with the washington times knoxville
detailed his decision saying it was at
the point where i either say yes to my
friends where we had all the control or
yes to saturday night live where none of
my friends were really going to be there
and i had no control i just thought i
made the right decision knoxville told
the hollywood reporter that his role on
snl would have consisted of him doing
solo stunts each week he told the outlet
they were going to give me like five
minutes each week to do what i do but
that would just be me and i couldn't do
both our show was about to go so i kind
of bet on us as opposed to on myself i
wasn't going to have complete control
like we did on jackass it was
a smart move in 2005 knoxville hosted
snl proving that with a little patience
you can have your cake and eat it too
johnny knoxville might live a wild and
crazy lifestyle on the screen but
off-screen he's a family man he's a
father of three and has been married
twice knoxville and his ex-wife melanie
cates had a daughter named madison now
an adult who lives in austin as of 2021
yet the two have since divorced and
knoxville is now married to naomi nelson
the couple had two children together
rocco and arlo to no one's surprise
knoxville doesn't want his kids to
follow in his stunt performing footsteps
he told access in a 2010 interview
pranks are fine no stunts i don't want
rocco or madison doing any stunts as
you'd expect his parenting techniques
are far different than his acting
methods as gq noted in a 2021 interview
quote knoxville is notably attentive to
the physical safety of his children
johnny knoxville has endured his fair
share of injuries over the years while
shooting jackass but there's one
incident that really stands out in 2007
knoxville tours urethra during a
motorcycle stunt gone wrong while
shooting jackass presents matt hoffman's
tribute to evel knievel when i came off
the ramp i let go the bike he goes 20
feet in the air and comes down and
breaks its handlebars off in my crotch
so
yeah knoxville said in a 2021 gq
interview i wasn't even supposed to do
anything i think i just showed up that
day and someone kind of threw out that i
should try and backflip a motorcycle i'm
like oh yeah i got that the result the
crash led to knoxville having to
self-administer a catheter for the next
three years but he took it all in stride
telling gq at the time i was like i
can't wait to tell the story everybody
loves a good story
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
jackass are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one